well
[Music]
hello how are you greetings to him and
jaramillo with his brief informative today
tuesday july 27 monsoon storms
wreaked havoc around the valley
gusts of winds between
60 to 70 miles per hour were reported today several
residents and workers have been seen
picking up fallen trees and clearing
mud and dirt from streets there were
several flood warnings in the
southwest valley including the
program and some residents of the
mount en search community
said flooding in this region has always
been a
problem as  more cases emerge youth
before clark county leaders are
trying to vaccinate more people
commissioners want to reach more
youth as delta variant
becomes more
contagious driver becoming more mainstream driver
changing clinic hours
to  adapt to people who
work different hours also
fill clinics to laundering  s of automobiles
workplaces and shopping malls
if you or your family have not yet received
the cob vaccine and there are
vaccination clinics at
las vegas' fire station number 48 near it
when and fort apache not required to
do
Make an appointment with the Babies Bound organization if you continue
in your efforts to help the
community tomorrow they have scheduled a
diaper bank for
needy families if you need supplies
for your baby you can go to the
recreation center from nine in the morning
until noon
remember that you have to  register
before arriving at the center and you can
do it by visiting the organization that you see
on your screen babies bounty dot org
and if you are looking for a job the
investor hotel company will hold several
fairs between today and August 5 at
the corriere center located near
trust in  it coins from 9 in the morning
until 4 in the afternoon to find out
more about the fairs you can visit
andrew's website  resorts
now we pass with your weather forecast
after several days of
monsoon storms today tuesday will be sunny and
temperatures reaching 100 degrees
by thursday heat is expected to
return to the valley with highs
in the 105s forecast and more expected by the weekend
storms that have a good
newspaper, Jaramillo is installed with his brief
informative for Disney in Spanish
[Music]